ننتقل اليك حسان المشهد على الجانب الاخر
ورد الفعل على هذه
العمليات التصعيد الواضح الذي قام به حزب
الله اليوم على الجبهه على امتدادها هنا
في الجليل الاعلى واصبع الجليل مع الحدود
مع لبنان عبر عمليات اعلن عنها الجيش
الاسرائيلي
وتحدث عن اصابات احدى هذه الاصابات كانت
لضابط اصيب بجروح خطره وجنديين ايضا
باصابات وصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالطفيفة وهذا التصعيد قوبل بشكل واضح
بتصعيد على مستويين المستوى الاول هو
التصعيد العسكري حيث قامت طائرات الجيش
الاسرائيلي بالاغانه على عدد كبير من
البلدات اللبنانيه في الجنوب واعلن الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن استهدافه لقواعد عسكريه
ومبان وبنى تحتيه كما قال لحزب الله في كل
من الخيام وكفر كيلا وكذلك طير حرفا فيما
ايضا ايضا قبل بتصعيد واضح عبر تبني الجيش
الاسرائيلي بشكل واضح لعمليه اغتيال لما
قال انه كادر في حزب الله ووصفه بانه قائد
اقليمي وهو كان مسؤولا عن المنطقه التي
استه استهدفت منها كريات ش مونا خلال هذا
اليوم وذلك عبر مسيره هذا التصعيد
الميداني ايضا قبل بتصعيد في التصريحات من
قبل مسؤولين اسرائيليين جاء ذلك على لسان
قائد القوات الجويه الاسرائيليه الذي توعد
حزب الله بانه سيواصل دفع الثمن لما يقوم
به على الجبهه الشماليه وان الطائرات
الحربيه التي هي بالعشرات كما قال في جنوب
لبنان يمكن ان تصبح بالمئات في اي لحظه
يتم فيها الاعلان عن بدء عمليه عسكريه او
عن اعطاء الاوامر لتكثيف العمليات
العسكريه في جبهه لبنان
مسعود مراسل الجزيره من الجليل الاعلى
شكرا لك